salut c'est alain reille bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle vidéo oh [ __ ] josep
franch et les amis bienvenue ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait une petite
vidéo mabala disparu c'est une longue
histoire qui explique aussi pourquoi
j'ai un suçon sur le nez qui n'a pas été
fait par un humain calmez vous tout de
suite ni par un animal calmez-vous
encore plus vous serez le pourquoi du
comment d'sa d'environ deux semaines je
vais pas vous parler aujourd'hui n'est
pas là pour parler de ça on est là pour
parler d'un fan game souvenez vous il ya
neuf mois pour être exact on avait fait
une vidéo sur un fan game ou un fan
s'était amusé à faire vraiment un jeu
avec une petite histoire c'est hyper
cool ils avaient modélisé ma maison et
ça m'avait littéralement bouleversé
parce que c'était hyper réaliste vous
avez maintenant deux secondes pour
deviner qui m'a envoyé un mail hier diot
squeeze ça y est c'est aujourd'hui plein
d'émotion que je t'envoie cette version
finale du chapitre 2 j'espère ce nouveau
chapiteau plaira et qui paiera la
communauté donc je vous rappelle que
dans le en gros il ya des gens qui me
faisait revenir dans le passé pour
fouiller mémoire en pensant que j'étais
mort mais j'étais pas mort donc je
revivais moi-même vraiment ont passé
bref après qu'ils essaient de donner
dans le présent l'inconnu du guide ans
au travers du tall qui a étrangement
réussi à les stopper mais celui ci vient
de se faire enlever sous tes yeux par
quelqu'un que tu connais bien tu te
réveilles perdu dans le temps comment en
est on arrivé là
qu'est ce qui a pu provoquer tout ça
seras tu capable de sauver jumbo vous
trouvé l'homme au talkie voire plus
sauver le monde pour avoir ça tu vas te
faire éclater une bonne dizaine de fois
sourit sourire le mec met les points sur
les i c'est parti
el arif qui arrive
c'est un [ __ ] de lampes propice aux
fins qui squeeze des benjamins ok ça
joue chapitre 2 les origines
alors on est dans le laboratoire squeeze
voilà je possède actuellement propre
laboratoire ça c'est un employé à moi
bien sûr clément tu vas très changé il
m'a dit de regarder un peu partout il ya
des petits détails a pas raté
administration sky art et un stagiaire
personne connaît son nom
j'irais bien ce qui paraît dr michael
aux avocats commis d'office le premier
qui va me faire chier pendant une de mes
parties dover rouge pendant que je
travaille sera reçu avec un coup de pied
au cul m&m et caressant qui mène dans
les jeux mais qu'at il fait le mec
regarde là ce [ __ ] de week end ils
l'ont fait avec une bonne calvitie c'est
ce qui attend quelques années mais car
jumbo notre sauveur sa super loin le
grand j des experts botaniste oh la la
il a calé des poteaux dr bossman
scientifique de l'année mac faye carlito
ossature pas ce qu'ils font dans cette
entreprise
ah ah rapaille ne pas approcher cet
individu coiffure pouvant varier tête ou
pressurisée type diminue mais quand de
l'ach taille 170 cm yes il m'a respectée
ça me fait plaisir le 169 cm il est plus
là mon gars du cru au lit en concert au
la petite pub pour bischu holly
calmement il sait bien les mecs o'shea
omer je suis câblo non non je vais
crever
oh [ __ ] ça à partir en faillite sa
part en fait mais que j'ai un pied de
biche et crois moi on va pas faire de
mécanique ou d'un fonction de porte dans
son chalet a parlé au [ __ ] tu t'es
parti en couille allume la lampe torche
bordel ouais ça va il m'a agressé [ __ ]
et sexuelle nul au silk ya sept fils de
chien [ __ ] pardonnez moi je vais créer
pas mal je vous préviens avance mais il
m'a fait peur aussi un fils de chien yes
[ __ ] ma plage et du skill en fait tu
peux vraiment crevé la mécano lendemain
de soirée comme les autres jouer je me
casse va pas chercher l'embrouillé avec
l'espèce de petit alien de merde à on
s'en va d'ici watts deux eaux
j'ai plus de vie mais qui me reste que
40 hp alors faut que j'aille là assez
fort j'ai peur du débat il ya des
pailles et un mec au slalom
vous l'avez vu c'était là le mec on va
devoir aller voir un mais il est con ça
va exploser
assez fort ah [ __ ] à yaya un conduit
françois ne conduit au quai nouveau
chapitre bon on a eu un gun on a eu un
viol mais on va économiser les bars là
quoi qu on en a 34 en effet au maire
devait oublier les couches des mythes
oh [ __ ] tu en es tu meurs ici c'est
chez moi verrouillé par carte d'accès
merde je passe par la noise day j'ai
peut-être tiré beaucoup trop de balles
par beaumont ce que c'était mais je me
suis dit ok il t'observe d'accord en
tout cas ils savent pas mettre dedans
postroff un sas et ça c'est clair
il ya un téléphone qui sonne bien ouais
ouais ok c'est cool tu es une personne
très glauque d'accord et pas sympathique
en bleu se trouvait son signe
astrologique pour voir un bureau ça n'a
aucun sens déjà ce n'est que tous les
mecs qui sont nés comme sur mes potes
mois peut vraiment bureau moi c'est
verso ainsi jamais alors cadavres si la
nonna non furoncle non squeeze flèche
avec un k way et déjà déjà inspecté moi
[ __ ] ça là qu'il faut trouver
l'assassin verso ça soit les colis à ben
verso un verre d'eau est un jeu de mot
et non pour les amis je galère tous les
coups on va l'appeler directement abbas
et pratique un d'avoir le numéro du def
du jeu oui oui bios et lucas ça va bien
écoute je trouve pas mon signe
astrologique
je sais ce que c'est bon signe
astrologique mais je ne trouve pas dans
le jeu sur les murs j'ai cherché partout
partout partout et ce qu'il est et ce
qui est bien sûr un mur ou pas du tout
[ __ ] j'ai échoué je suis dégoûté vers
le début ok bah écoutes je me démerde et
hop là je te rappelle si besoin
merci de ta il est génial en plus je
suis dégouté je suis en train d'échouer
les amis la [ __ ] aller là non on ne
sait pas ce que je dois faire
merde peut-être que s'est ouvert le
bureau en fait attend on va voir mais
peut-être qu'il ya des nouveaux monstres
m étonnerait pas on va se méfier à
prendre après attiré à grand papa de
rihanna attention
et vraiment benjamin je vais t'appeler
je te mettre une attention alors le
bureau et s'il va s'ouvrir ce bâtard yes
i'm bad tinqueux alors yacco dans ce
[ __ ] de bureaux carte d'accès aux
quais maintenant chez fo a laissé cette
porte la pelure au docteur deux croates
vcsd à survie en milieu hostile
entrée interdite car il est vraiment
arrêt me mais qu ils ont du coup fait
demi-tour au mouret hommes et mexes et
la suite du jeu je peux pas m'arrêter
dernière investissements mais non mes
mecs mais je suis obligée d'y aller
non mais un problème
bah ouais mais qu elles marqueront flag
et emmerdent ya en tout cas fait en fait
je trouve quoi faire mr dame à merde je
pense qu'en fait faut juste que je me
baisse
si je me blesse je meurs pas un drame
non comment je vais m'en bats les
couilles je rappelle ben ça m'énerve
[Musique]
si j'ai trouvé ce que j'ai pas trouvé
c'est comment échapper au fusil à pompe
du mec bourré regarde surtout au début
ok excellent merci à très vite je dois
tellement le décevoir le pauvre ben il
se dit [ __ ] mais pourquoi ne pas faire
un jeu pour un mix m et d'en faire un
fossé que le pauvre alors on est bien là
mais qu'on a un pont que maintenant
c'est lourd ça y est ça y est merde
batta peut en tout cas faire il ya un
truc sur lequel tire est maintenant je
connais l'astuce waouh c'est d'un
resident evil ça o'shea au 15 juin
prochain ce matin qu'il doit faire mais
mais mais mais c'est chaud non je suis
nulle [ __ ] faut semer sur le rebord
pour sauter ah ouais bah j'avais fait je
suis juste nul alors eh ben attention
attention aux c'est le dernier ou pas oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a fait peur aux quais
pour faire gauche droite ça est juste à
l'homme
[Musique]
hu
hop
super choses s'arrêtent jamais ok mais
alors est allé faut mettre un petit
claude françois dans les oreilles on est
bon c'est parti c'est chaud c'est un
[ __ ] je viens et mais avec l'autre
soir ces pièces place attention au mieux
je crois que ça passe
cette année tard non non il y en a pas
encore non merci on décapite mais qu'est
ce qu'ils peuvent mais il est fou au
poteau mais comme en témoigna de laser
la attend peut-être avant que ça se
forment attendant jeu des devinettes
pièce c'est bon je suis pas ça moi que
ça se forment et ben il va être fier de
moi j'ai pas besoin d'appeler pour
résoudre ça ok ou à la six mois c'est la
dernière ligne droite
attention robot mode b termine on
l'avait dit rambo mode chier tu la
fermes ses prières
bayonne oui car c'est qu'il profite à
arette maxence guest de la vie à sept le
boss final au
[Musique]
à
mais tabarnak mais s'essouffle aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe ça y est
témoin la paix maintenant [ __ ] ça
rigolait pas ses preuves la gent peuples
eux mêmes endormi pourquoi est mauvais
mais je lui fais quoi j'ai fait quoi ce
mec
ah oui c'est beau ça comment je peux
plus attendre la période c'est
incroyable les amis c'est la fin de ce
premier épisode y en aura que deux et je
préfère divisé en deux séances a fait
une vidéo d'une heure et c'est quand
même un peu long on est actuellement à
la moitié du jeu il m'avait prévenu ben
may fait bon quand elle chante pas tout
c'est la moitié merci ben omar a prévenu
pas merci marc a fait autant souffrir au
niveau des lasers maigre butin j'ai
vraiment cru que j'allais arrêter que
j'allais rage quit et que cette vidéo
n'allait pas sortir etc toriko des
millers un truc qui finalement ne sert à
rien chef je vous dis à bientôt pour la
seconde partie du coup ça sort
incessamment sous peu vous en faites pas
je vous fais plein de bisous je vous dis
à très haut dans une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
ça